I'm Deli everybody if you're obsessed
with true crime documentaries it may pay
off one day police say A store owner
recognized an Illinois girl who had been
abducted years ago because of the latest
iteration of Unsolved Mysteries on
Netflix here's a little bit of
background for you so Kayla unbehon was
nine years old when her mother who only
had visitation rights apparently ran off
with her while they were supposed to be
on a camping trip Kayla's Father Ryan
had full custody of her when she
disappeared in 2017 and fast forward to
2023 When A store owner in Asheville
North Carolina recognized Kayla from the
Unsolved Mysteries reboot the employee
called police and Heather unbehon was
arrested she's awaiting extradition from
North Carolina back to Illinois Kayla is
in protective custody for now and is
expected to be reunited with her father
during the years that Kayla was missing
the national Center for missing and
exploited children shared missing
posters that included an age progression
for now Heather is charged with one
count of child abduction so Terry right
now that Kayla has been located do you
think it could be difficult reuniting
her with her father I don't want it to
be too difficult they have room
protective custody because they have to
determine whether or not the father or
any other parental individual is in a
position where they can take care of her
both physically mentally emotionally and
so we know for a fact she's not going to
go back to her mother because obviously
her mother abducted her and she's going
to be subjected to criminal charges and
she may very well be in jail but one of
the things that they do in Illinois is
the child even a minor can determine
where they want to live so if there are
other relatives she could actually
consider some of that and Illinois will
also offer her some sort of counseling
because of what she's been through it's
a very traumatic incident and it's a
very difficult transition and Brian how
do abduction charges work when the
accused parent had custody of the child
at the time and this effect child
custody going forward yeah so Jesse as
you said earlier the father had full
custody the mother had a visitation and
while the child may be with the mother
at that time so she has custody of the
child at that time it doesn't really
matter either parent whether they have
full custody or not the court has said
that there are visitation schedules that
they're in the middle of some sort of a
family law proceeding and one parent
can't decide for the other parent when
they get to see the child in terms of
how this is going to affect custody
going forward I think this mother might
be able might be losing what little
custody she has now she has visitation
rights they could be limited going
forward maybe she's not going to have
visitation on her own she has to be
supervised by maybe your grandma grandpa
or even the father when she sees the
child maybe the child can't even go to
her home she has to come to the father's
home to see the child or she loses
visitation altogether it's going to be a
horrible mess for her not just from a
family law standpoint but also criminal
well listen I'm just glad safe return
unbelievable story right there well this
next story introduces us to an unusual
weapon lunch meat if Florida officer
responded to a smoke shop in a strip
mall after the clerk reported a man
outside was causing a disturbance and
when the officer tried to talk to the
man things escalate did
I call about him calling a disturbance
and he's coming here quite a few times
already and it's bothered me and
customers it makes me very uncomfortable
I was arrested eight months ago and I
spent 18 months in prison
I'm so glad to be out but anyways I'm
suing
the Volusia County Sheriff I'm suing
this is all with my lawyers currently
underway what's your question just wait
for that if I sue the Port Orange to the
police department and they give me 250
000 that's tax free right I have no idea
okay I'll have to talk to my accountant
about that no she said that she wrote my
stuff up
okay go after you
okay come over here
get the fuck out of you come on
okay you can't do it I know I don't want
to do it I feel the karate black belts
you know you understand your trespass
from the store correct
okay
go ahead arrest me arrest my central
second unit go too
wait a minute
lawsuit I'm suing you for a million I'm
10 million whatever
and welcome back everybody a middle
school teacher was suspended and
arrested on Friday after authorities say
that he made terroristic threats to
students in his classroom 46 year old
David Schroeder is a Jewish seventh
grade teacher in Crafton in Grafton
Wisconsin authorities say he berated his
students after finding a swastika drawn
on a notebook in his classroom according
to the criminal complaint he told the
students he had quote 17 guns in his
basement and then he was not afraid to
use them other threats reportedly made
included sending his daughter to their
homes with a baseball bat and wishing
pain on them and their families one
student from the class told local media
that the teacher said swastikas were
worse than quote writing the n-word on
the wall the teacher was removed from
the school when a student reported his
behavior to administrators he's now on
leave while the investigation continues
Schroeder faces a felony charge of
making terrorist threats and was booked
in jail on ten thousand dollars bail his
next hearing is scheduled for June let's
break it down so Terry clearly this
teacher overreacted but what should be
he what should he have done you know
under these circumstances well one of
the things he has to think about doing
is protecting the other students who
obviously didn't write the swastika I
mean they are being bullied in that
classroom and he has to find out where
that started from so he can work with
the administration he can talk to the
parents and find out how it started so
his job in that classroom is not only to
teach but to protect the students from
being bullied and I agree this is a very
offensive act to write something like
this and it is as offensive as the
n-word particularly to a lot of people
and so I definitely think that you know
he should have reacted but the way he
reacted was even more offensive to those
students and it probably frightened them
and caused more problems than it would
have if he had just handled it
appropriately well Brian I mean he
overreacted sure but you know a
terrorist threat sounds like a very
serious charge didn't he just get overly
angry and you know maybe understandably
so seeing that yeah Jesse from a legal
and factual standpoint I don't see a
terroristic threat a terroristic threat
is often about you trying to coerce a
public of course the public a government
entity or even law enforcement to change
a policy uh politics uh actions or
something like that through threats or
intimidation
this is just a horrible teacher cursing
at a bunch of kids I'm not defending him
in any way shape or form from a moral
standpoint he should probably lose his
job and never be allowed to to teach
children again but terroristic threat
that goes a little bit far I'm not even
sure if it's a true threat I'm thinking
about the Supreme Court case Watson
United States where the guy said if you
put a gun in my hands the first person
I'm going to put in my sights is LBJ
that wasn't a threat so it's the right
thing to kill the president threatening
to do this to kids not a threat I think
it'll be a tough time for the
prosecution all right I mean listen it's
a complicated case and a sad case all
around uh but we'll continue to follow
and see where it goes when we come back
New York City lawmakers passed a new
bill this month preventing
discrimination based on height and
weight up next we're breaking down the
Bill's social impact and potential legal
implications
[Music]
we're finishing Today's Show right here
in New York City where council members
passed a bill just last week Banning
discrimination based on people's height
and weight the Discrimination ban
impacts spaces like housing employment
and public accommodations according to a
study at Vanderbilt University women
considered to be obese earn more than
five dollars less per hour than women
considered to be of normal weight
the study further shows that among the
40 percent of U.S adults considered
obese women of color are the highest
demographic facing weight-based
discrimination according to the bill
complaints about weight discrimination
would be investigated by the city's
Commission on human rights the
commission already handles complaints
over things like race gender and
pregnancy exemptions to the bill include
jobs or weight or height are essential
for public health and safety reasons
Seven Cities now have similar laws in
place plus the entire state of Michigan
state level bills have been introduced
in New York Massachusetts Vermont and
New Jersey this week we interviewed two
activists about the ongoing problem and
the Bill's ultimate goal in combating it
when we cite examples of the kinds of
discrimination that people face not
talking just about like sort of
um interpersonal attitudes about fat but
actually like life-changing
discrimination things like being
prevented from medical treatment things
like being paid unfairly on your job
things like being
um you know treated unfairly by your
landlord those kinds of things and
people kind of go like wait that's okay
like that's that's the law lets you do
that and in fact the law does let you do
that in most places in the United States
um you know people can seek legal
recourse anytime they are discriminated
against but it is much easier to have
success seeking that recourse if there
is a law that explicitly protects you
it's a civil rights issue and folks
should not be discriminated against
based on their size
um and it also disproportionately
impacts certain communities of color so
oftentimes it's sort of this legal
loophole of a way that you know if
you're discriminating based on someone's
height and weight
um your food it's their legal to
discriminate based on their race as well
and there's continuing research that
just demonstrates over and over again
that fat is not as mutable as people
think it is
um but even if it were is that the world
that we want to live in one where like
it's okay to discriminate against people
if they could just change that thing or
um do we want to be allowed to be Who We
Are
and not face legal discrimination
because of that now the one piece of
criticism that we are hearing about the
bill tends to be focused on whether it's
going to create a bunch of lawsuits and
where where our goal is not actually to
see a whole bunch of people get sued
over these regulations our goal is to
see a whole bunch of people make change
because they don't want to be sued over
these regulations
so Terry you handled civil rights cases
in the past do you think this new law is
progressed forward I do think it's
progress for it look you have some
rights obviously the courts have in both
state and federal given rights as far as
civil rights are concerned so race
religion those are two of the rights
that are protected based on a particular
description of a group that has expanded
over the years if you think about it age
is now protected you have everything
from gender to Identity that's being
protected whether it's in state or
whether it's in federal law so I think
having this societal issue raised is a
good thing and you're going to see over
time that there are more issues that are
raised I think where you don't
discriminate and you hurt the experts
they are talking about why would you
discriminate against anybody for any
reason so I think it's a good you know
move forward and I think we're going to
see other areas as well well Brian this
is a New York law so what do you think
is going to happen if it gets challenged
all the way to the Supreme Court what
would they do Jesse let me make sure I'm
speaking very carefully and not using
the wrong words so people come after me
for this but what I think is if it's a
question of whether or not you're going
to make height and weight a protected
class as opposed to saying that you
shouldn't discriminate based on those
two things which are two different
things because you shouldn't
discriminate based on anything
especially heightened weight or any
immutable uh characteristic I think
that's one thing but saying it should be
a protected class based on the case law
that we have now going to creating
making gender protected classes
orientation of protected glass I think
it would take a lot of educating and a
lot of putting similar facts as to other
groups that are protected into the same
kind of casing or holding that we have
as to why we protect based on race and
gender and I think it's difficult at
this standpoint but maybe with some more
stats in education on how weight and
height affect people that could be
changed all right it's an interesting
question Terry Bryan thank you so much
everyone out there thanks for joining us
here on the daily we're going to see you
next time as we discuss Justice in
America
foreign